[Music]
president biden yesterday with a warning
to unvaccinated americans
winter is coming and it's going to be
bad
we're unvaccinated
we are looking at a winner of severe
illness and death for unvaccinated
for themselves their families and the
hospital they'll soon overwhelm
but
there's good news if you're vaccinated
you have your booster shot you're
protected from severe illness and death
period
this as the president's response to the
pandemic gets its worst marks to date a
new fox business poll shows nearly half
of you half of america disapproves of
his performance on covet now all right
here we are south dakota governor
christie gnomes so it's going to be a
dark winter it looks like governor what
do you plan on doing to your people
i we plan on doing business as usual and
celebrating christmas i think the
president's outlook
is focusing on the negatives this
country needs hope they need to remember
the promise of christmas and the love
they have for their families and friends
and enjoy the season but the numbers are
rising and he's concerned are you
we're always concerned we're doing the
hard work of taking care of people
letting them use personal responsibility
to make the best decisions for
themselves and their families and then
focusing on how we can get through
challenging times together south dakota
has been an example to the country of
how you do that with common sense and
protecting freedoms and i would
encourage the president to consider
taking some of the actions that we have
for instance what because
to brian's point the numbers are rising
the number of hospitalizations in the
last two weeks of 20 percent
they are expecting governor in about
three weeks the death toll because of
covet largely delta will be 15 000 per
week here in the united states so what
common sense things
are is south dakota doing that the
president should do
we will continue to do what we've done
throughout the pandemic and that's to
inform people give them the data focus
on the science encourage them to
consistently wash their hands like we
did throughout the pandemic to make sure
that they're they're not feeling well
they should stay home protect the
vulnerable individuals and choose to get
a vaccine if they would like to if they
don't then go into this knowing that
they should focus on exercising taking
their vitamin vitamins and being very
healthy people governor i know that you
want to introduce the girls sports bill
tell the folks at home what this is and
why
well we did file that bill this week we
go into session in january but this bill
would essentially take uh the executive
orders that i put in place last year and
codify them into state law and what they
do is protect fairness in women's sports
for girls make sure that they have the
opportunity to be successful that we
only have girls playing in girls sports
it would address it at the k-12 level
but also at the collegiate level here in
our state it's complicated because there
are now trans athletes who are competing
in sports in gender
in the categories
for genders that they were not born at
people who were born born as boys are
now
trans and now competing with women
there are very physical differences
between males and females and that is
one of the issues that we're talking
about is the biological differences and
making sure that we're protecting girls
sports so that girls have a level
playing field they have the opportunity
to be successful and that's something
that was fought for many years ago that
we here in south dakota will protect
that right for those girls boys should
play in boys sports and girls should
play in girls sports right this leah
thomas is the swimmer he's at the
university of pennsylvania uh switched
sexes uh now woman uh competing and
blowing out the competition uh and it
turns out a lot of the teammates a lot
of the parents of the teammates of our
own teammates are upset about this they
had their own goals they had they had
races they wanted to win
and here's a quote from a female swimmer
speaking out against thomas it's hard
working your whole life at a sport and
going to the big competition seeing
someone who is more physically talented
than you however it's even more
discouraging to have them right next to
you and knowing you won't ever be on the
same physical level as them
so that is exactly what this is about
isn't it
it is and i think a lot of people across
the country are trying to take this
issue
and make it into personal beliefs or to
send a message on a different issue when
really what this comes down to is
fairness fairness for girls giving them
a level playing field so that when they
compete in these sports
they can be successful and they have the
opportunity to go on
go to college get scholarships be a
professional and make sure that they're
competing against someone who was given
the same gifts and the same level of
physical abilities that they were yeah
governor before you go we'll have you
weigh in on some politics over the last
week or so there's been some speculation
about whether or not joe biden would run
for re-election and in fact the new york
times on the op-ed page said joe don't
run but tell people now what do you
think is going to happen on the democrat
side
now i think the president and the vice
president have discussed this issue i
think they disagree on the best path
forward for their party they've got a
lot of division going on and it'll be
interesting to watch what they do in the
future what i know
is the policies of republicans are
working they're creating opportunities
our economies are growing people are
successful
and republicans and conservatives are
happier because we recognize that what
we believe truly does protect what makes
america so special so you believe
there's division between joe biden and
kamala harris
i do you can you can see it between them
uh that they aren't communicating
they're not getting along and i think
there's a lot of division in the white
house right now between those two well
he says he's running again and she says
she says we haven't discussed it does
that mean he possibly is looking for
another candidate to be his vp well look
at look at the democratic party i mean
their
their leadership obviously has a poor
ability to decide when to step down
they're they've got nancy pelosi steny
hoyer joe biden they've got young
leaders that are frustrated because
they've got a very different agenda for
this country it's interesting to watch
what's going on in the democratic party
because i don't believe it reflects
america right now and the american
public is waking up to it that's why
parents are showing up at meetings
school boards city councils uh they're
taking their country back and i think
that means that it's going to be a great
midterms for republicans right they feel
optimistic about the house and we'll see
what's going to happen in the senate
remember in loudoun county all those
parents that pan parent panel like we
had like 12 of them they all said we
didn't even know who our school board
members were and now we all speak out at
the meeting right to your point a lot of
frustration governor thank you very much
for joining us today merry christmas
governor
merry christmas thank you guys have a
wonderful holiday
indeed all right
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now